if I studying conversation well joining
me now has talk TV presenter Sharon
Osborne the time political sketch writer
Quentin let's talk to the contributor
Esther crack you well well I wasn't
expecting that actually uh Sharon Lord
dannick giving that kind of take on on
Harry and actually found it quite moving
because he knows him from his military
time clearly feels very sad about what's
happened but you know try as part of his
positivity
um call trying to see if there's a way
back for him what do you think well I
felt the same when I when I saw him back
in this country and I saw him part of
the royal family again it made me very
sad
I I honestly felt sad that you know this
is his home this is where he belongs the
country loved him so much and I'm sure
they still do the majority and it's just
like
listen nobody knows what goes on in any
family let alone the royal family but
was it so drastic that you had to turn
to California to live a life like a
celebrity yeah Clinton lets you're a
brilliant sketch right so I don't even
know where you start with the daylight
today well I think you start with the
fact that it was a state occasion it was
very very stately and it's been a
brilliant success in that respect well
you've moved personally by I was less
moved today than I expected to be until
Westminster until uh Windsor right and
uh I thought the Windsor service perhaps
because I had a bit more cranma to it a
bit more prayer book to it uh and didn't
was not quite so encumbered by stately
Majesty I thought that uh Windsor sort
of got me going a bit more but the
silence in the uh The Abbey service
between the last post and ravallik yeah
that was a very powerful and also the
arrival of the coffin uh being pulled by
the naval ratings they came on and the
the music stopped and then they did 15
extra pieces and then halted yeah and as
they marched they were marching on Sand
it made a strange sound it made it sound
a bit like shaking brown sugar in a in a
packet uh very powerful just the sound
of those marching footsteps coming to a
halt that that was one a moment that
stood out some people are seeing this as
a kind of re-energized view to the world
of what Britain does best and therefore
fantastically positive and
forward-looking re-energizing the
monarchy others have said maybe this is
you know the beginning of the end this
is the top it's ever going to be that
this Monarch was as great as we could
ever expect and would actually support
for the monarchy will now slowly start
to fade away what do you think well I
suspect that the poll numbers if you
judge these things by polls which I
don't by poll ratings then uh possibly
there will be a little bit of a decline
for a bit because that's inevitable
after such an enormous Peak like this
but what you saw today and what you've
seen the last 10 10 days is the public
saying we are proud of our country we
are proud of our Crown we like things
the way that they are we think this is a
pretty good place to live and um the the
way that that has been asserted by the
public will be absorbed by politicians
and I think perhaps the political class
will be less beholden to Twitter in the
future the problem with the political
class it seems to me in comparison to
say this queen in particular we never
knew what she thought about anything and
in fact if anything ever got leaked it
was a big history of all time because we
just never heard what what her thoughts
were publicly about anything
didn't mean she didn't have them she
just didn't Express them in public
policy was not disputation she was the
opposite of she was a completely
unifying person she was she was a fount
of calm right so how so how do
politicians who necessarily take strong
positions on issues which are
necessarily politically polarizing how
can they hope to emulate that kind of
unifying Spirit and the same applies in
America where it's almost impossible now
everything is split down the middle half
the country believes one thing about
most stuff after country and there's
notes coming to United it is the United
States
I think the politicians I mean the
answer to that is the politicians have
to disagree because debate is essential
but it's not so toxic but at the same
time they need to take their their lead
much less from that engine over anchor
that is social media yes and uh I think
that too much of our politics and our
political discourse has been guided by
the ranker the latest Pilon from social
media yes these things really don't
matter right
other people make you today of King
Charles of the monarchy of the future
you're a young person I've actually seen
I was quite surprised I saw a lot of
posts on social media you know obviously
fitting farewell to the queen and
actually saying God Save the King I've
actually seen kind of an uptick in
patriotism but I wasn't expecting right
I'm I'm very curious though how the new
prime minister the relationship she will
have with King Charles because he's
obviously very vocal on things like the
Rwanda policy on on the on green um
policy and all of that I just wonder
what sort of their weekly meetings will
be because it's a lot harder to well
funny enough Sharon and I were talking
about this on on Fox this afternoon and
I'd slight issue because Sharon you
think he's going to continue to be
outspoken about issues he cares about
because he's been proven right about
something absolutely um but I I think he
has made a decision that what now he's
Monarch he's not going to do this I
really think he's decided that the only
way to be a popular and long-surviving
Monarch beloved the people like his
mother is just to Simply stop making
public pronouncements about anything
that is remotely political and that
would include things like climate change
which are dear to itself so I just don't
think we're going to see them do that I
I the one thing that you did say was
absolutely right that you're never going
to please the mob it's always going to
be half of it that's against you yeah so
whatever opinion you expect me you know
I could go on Twitter and say you know I
love Monday right as a day and within 10
minutes that would be the most
unbelievable part of the people agreeing
with me oh I love it I love Monday night
favorite day of the year and here's why
other people say are you mad if you lost
your mind Monday's the worst day of all
time in other words everything has to
immediately lead to an extreme reaction
everything has to be a toxic debate it
can't be just a bit of fun uh and that's
the way in particular social media has
whipped every one of the kind of
permanent lava and I don't I don't
divorce myself from part of this by the
way because I quite often get sucked in
and start you know having a very
consensual figure right I'd like to
think that I am somebody who expresses
firmly helpful in the water
I'm not taking divisive lectures from
you less one of the most brilliant and
yet pungent writers in the business I
don't think Charles can possibly become
political he can't can it he can't uh
and if he looks at his mother's record I
mean he can't continue to be political
because he has been I continue to do
that and I think he accepted that on the
the first Friday when he said my role is
now going to change yes and he has to
just pull back from that and be a much
more a tranquil presence and and you
have to be I do hope I do hope that I
mean his is a face that that naturally
frowns a lot yeah I want my king I'm
proud of King Charles I love smile more
I want him to smile more yeah yeah and
he's he's good at laughter
yeah so far in his Reign he's been
mourning his mother of course and I
think that's easy he's had to tour the
country probably take 100 phone calls a
day from world leaders and stuff he's
against console console his family show
us his King I mean the pressure on the
guy is just unbelievable he took it out
on a pen that's how bad things are and
Sharon what does it say about our
country today do you think what did you
feel when you were watching it were you
getting emotional about a country from
the past that we're slightly losing or
have lost or did you feel in a way it
was a good chance to
three focuses on what makes this country
great
a bit of both yeah really appears a bit
of both I love the way that the whole
country was so United and so together
and there was so much positivity when
you would go into the streets and yet
there are you know certain groups here
that are against royalty but I think
overall I think the Royal royalty I hope
to God is safe here yeah I mean I think
so but I think it would be
we have a special thing a sporty odd
monarchies left in the world of which 12
the European you could take all the
European worlds outside of ours down
Tottenham Court Road nobody really are
right
um so I think that we are in a very
unique position with our monarchy it is
a unique institution in terms of Fame
and Global Renault right I think it's in
safe hands I think one of the things I
would say about the younger generation
we're generally excited about William
and Kate and I think what would be
really smart for Charles to do is to
draw on that any sort of engagements
that he has that you know is very near
and dear to his heart he should actually
make sure that William is very present
there because it's kind of like handing
down what's going to happen acquainting
with the Commonwealth you know you're
seeing Jacinda ardern from New Zealand
saying it's inevitable that in her
lifetime New Zealand will go Republic
Australia's flirting with it has a new
leader Anthony who is certainly you know
not being full-on Republican but
certainly indicated that he may go that
way if the people wanted it you'll see
some of the Caribbean countries
immediately indicating they want to have
referendums within several years you
know this could if he's not careful King
Charles III you could get a domino
effect if countries suddenly thinking
the Commonwealth as a concept is over I
think that uh the two slightly different
things being conflated there whether or
not Charles's head of state but whether
or not
um countries are part of the
Commonwealth it's two slightly different
things uh I think you have to let those
countries decide for themselves and to
try to resist that or try to impose
um uh our our family as their heads of
state as well we'll be entirely wrong
and counterproductive and so you live
and Let Live
these countries decide how much is the
is the racism allegation which Meghan
Markle the first biracial member of them
or family of course how much is her
racism claims do you think Esther had an
impact but certainly in in some of the
Caribbean countries I do think it's had
a negative impact but not as much as
people think because I don't think
they're highly respected figures Harry
and Megan I think they come across as
quite wingy and I generally think most
people that talk about the Commonwealth
don't understand it you know there's so
many people in the Commonwealth that
were glued to their TVs today there's so
many people from the Commonwealth that
actually are very fond of of the
monarchy and the royal family
um for various reasons I think one thing
I have noticed with thought sort of the
Republican wave is it's very cyclical in
terms of politics so you have a labor
leader in Australia you have Jason who
couldn't be more left-wing if she tried
you know they're always more on the
Republican side of things but again if
you know the elections swing the other
way and you have more right-leaning
governments in they're not probably
probably going to push for by the way
there was a moment today where if you've
done your sketch for tomorrow I've filed
because I've never spotted this but
there was no it was an Australian crew I
think it was uh there's a clip of an
Australian that we all had difficulty
today identifying public figures right A
lot of them were you know heads of
states which we just didn't recognize
and so on but you would have thought his
trust by the way have you seen this have
you seen this look at this
who's this no hard to identify maybe uh
minor Royals members of the I can't
identify them at this point
Unfortunately they look like they will
be local dignitaries it's hard to see
we're looking at the backs of their
heads but I think we are now getting to
the pointy end as they say of the
was I'm just told that was Liz trust the
new prime minister in the distance that
we could see helping him
on Australia those are the dregs
I recognized your prime minister Anthony
or benazi immediate in a national
American television you're too ahead of
me there but did you see the spider when
the when the coffin came been at the
west door and was being carried into the
Abbey there was a spider visible on the
wreath it was a lovely time I had a
lovely moment there was a living
creature on the coffins it was uh yeah I
mean I love moments like that Tony Blair
did you see Tony Blair wearing his
garter he needs a haircut I thought
um I think he was morphing back to his
old rock God days isn't it
yeah
what I'm told is I was asking someone
who's you know connected to one of the
prime ministers and all the living Prime
Ministers were there so you've got John
Major you've got Tony Blair Gordon
brownie with baby Cameron on Theresa May
and Boris Johnson and although
here's David Cameron today although this
is all that we're going to see coming
past here so
there's Gordon Brown so you have them
all all these incredibly different
people all of whom have been at long
hairs at various stages with each other
that's the wrong doctor
but it's it's an interesting thing that
apparently when they all get together
there is there is a shared commonality
of experience of being prime minister it
actually does bring them together a bit
except for major and Boris is that right
they will not talk really yeah is that
right beat daggers drawn it always kept
as far apart as possible own you know
only plastic knives when those two is it
really yeah
but it must be a strange Club there's
only six of them aren't there left it's
quite a lot we've never had so many uh
how many surviving there's only about
five six U.S presidents I mean these are
small clubs that people are in yeah
they've known the the codes to the
nuclear uh button and that that does
have a sort of um a gelling thing and
also they are in the body of the same
speakers uh um employment for American
Presidents isn't it it's how many are
still alive Trump I'm Obama Clinton
Carter yes and Carter's known as late
yeah
um Biden I thought should have been
given a more prominent position today I
thought it was a Pity that uh our most
important Ally wasn't perhaps given a
slightly better seat I think he was
really he was down down somewhere near
the dignitaries the top man from Andorra
I think was near him but you know that's
that's the Democracy of a church service
and what a a lot of fantastic scene
there was yes the the hymn singing I
thought I thought the chorus yeah
sure about some of the music in the ABIA
the MacMillan piece didn't really do did
you get emotional Sharon watching Barry
did you yeah what was the moment through
the whole day we were most affected do
you think just it was just one of those
days where you really
just wanted to concentrate on watching
every minute of it did you want to talk
to anyone I just wanted to watch it or
because as I said to you earlier it's
history yeah the moment for me actually
was when
um right at the end when a coffin
started to be lowered oh I found that
very very effective on me because I
thought well that really is the end
that's it that's going to be the last
time I see the queen I thought
this is it she's now with her husband
yes well that's the uplifting part of
the day he's not at the very start there
was at the Abbey there was the ringing
the tolling 96 times of the Kenner Bell
yeah to The Abbey and uh you'll have
been to uh English Country Church
funerals they do the same thing they
ring the bell they didn't read it 96
times of course yeah but the single Bell
summoning the faithful yeah and the
mornings to prayer and I thought that
was something that was because at the
heart of this was it was a state
occasion but it's also an Anglican
funeral yes and the Commendation when
the Archbishop Academy I've always been
his greatest fan uh Justin but well he
did it very well the accommodation at
the end where he said go forth a
Christian Soul yeah it was very touching
this was this was a narrow coffin there
narrow coughing did you notice that yeah
and there that was the focus on it was
on the onion uh thank you Sharon we're
going to love you and leave you thank
you very much Louis you're being
replaced for one of the world's greatest
historians I'm sure you won't mind there
he is waiting in the winds as we sell
them fasting to see what he thinks about
this from a historical perspective
there he is